with us a special guest we have a
special frenchman and a former candidate
maxine vasherlagraf welcome to the show
i'm sure that you've been
watching this with bated breath tell us
your opinions how's it going
hey
[Music]
it's been a long time also
we will be
in saint louis for united in august so
wonderful excellent we have the bug
house table waiting for you
really can't wait right uh your first
impressions about the candidates
um
well
one thing was not surprised for me is
that nepal was
playing good
like i thought it would perform well i
thought it would be one of the
contenders
uh i thought there would be four main
contenders for the victory so it would
it was
yam
it was fabi it was ding and it was ali
um that was my thought before the
tournament obviously some of the things
uh have not been going as uh i predicted
but uh
the two horses that are still you know
in the race are among these four
uh
talk about ali raza's performance uh
you're you're
you're a frenchman
exactly right
um yeah i must say
it's been a difficult tournament for him
although he must have been relieved that
he was out to
to win yesterday finally he's been
trying very hard
and there's been a few things that have
not been working for him
sometimes this preparation has been
working but lately it hasn't been so
great
in the last few games
and also his time management
has always been an issue i think
with him sometimes he was playing too
fast
uh lately he was playing too slow and
this time again i think he's tanking in
on some decisions where
he shouldn't really so
you know but
we can still see you know the potential
why
why is such a rising star where he
helped us to
uh to win the silver medal in european
team championship where he won the
countries so you know there's
definitely up for for the future for for
friends
with alive
and i yeah well it's quite interesting
so i knew alireza when he was yay high
he's the same age as my brother so they
would play in the same u championships
and i would prepare against him and it
was very fun i know he has a very very
supportive father and i do think that's
one of his huge success reasons is his
family support
on top of his own talent
but the other question i have two
questions for you question number one
uh is about the painting i'm sorry is
that a chess board in the middle of that
yeah okay nice it's it's not my painting
i'm not at my place oh okay we will not
ask where
i'm at a friend's place no nice that's
what it's a very capturing um
i was gonna compliment you on your good
taste as well get out of here you're
faking it it's fake news
news yeah you you don't want to see my
apartment
i thought it was a french impressionist
painting with some chessboards i thought
i thought it was maybe a goldfish retro
no that's a that's a chess board in the
middle that's very wonderful okay that
takes care of question number one
non-arts uh question
well what are your thoughts on the the
potential
idea that magnus will not play nepal if
he wins how do you where do you think
that's gonna go
well i think first that magnus is
generally brutally honest when he says
something
at least parts of him thinks that it's
true and so there's a very serious
chance
that he will not play if nepo or maybe
someone else wins
and i can understand that because of
course working uh
six months in advance for every
championship match
can be growing and it's been 10 years
for for magnus so
you know i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised if he sticks to to his opinion
i also wouldn't be surprised if he
decides to actually play like he said
it's a matter that's begging him and
that he's
thinking about himself
now the question is of course
whether he
if he actually wants
another type of cycle
for the world championship maybe not any
match
then he probably should offer
a replacement if if you really think
that's the way to go
i mean
there's an argument for that so it's uh
but it's definitely i mean the body
needs is in his cart
wonderful um
if i can turn your attention uh maxine
to
a position that you may be familiar with
the naidorf
ikaru versus yeah ali raza you get that
has been playing it in the opening was
not made of like it was most efficient
of light actually right right
um your take on the current opinion
position we've seen a trade on b3
d5 takes queen takes
and we are up to date with the players
after the move c2 c4
how would you break down the position
for our audience and
who stands better
i will say two things so
one thing
is that i think this position should be
better for white in general even though
there's uh chances
of course for ali reza because it's such
a dynamic position
king is still in the center but it's not
yet a big issue could become one in the
next two months but let's say there's
still time to castle
and second thing uh well i've been
played iko a few times
i think this is the kind of position
that you
kind of want to avoid against him
and
uh this is why i'm surprised that
arizona went straight into
um position where i'm gonna grow you on
that one when you say this type of
position is what you want to avoid with
ikar what what factors of the position
is it that you think hikaru does very
well
yeah it's just very open position lots
of things to calculate lots of potential
for initiative for ikaru like he's not
gonna be stuck in defense
and that's why i'm surprised because uh
if we
see the opening from the start work i
will play knight f3
after e5
lots of options
are just
you know like the main line is bishop e7
bishop c4
uh
castle and then bishop e6 it's just a
quite slow quite long game i mean i'm
not saying that ikaw is a bad player in
there for sure not but i think he's a
better player in the position we we
currently are have on the board
and uh yeah it just feels like this idea
could be interesting
but
like personally if i had been using this
idea it would have been against another
player
i see from
hikaru's point of view he's just played
the move c4
and it looks to me like that's a
preparatory move
to play d5 and
seize the open default maybe maybe rook
a5 and rook d5 same idea i kind of like
white's position uh maxine yeah that's
basically what i'm saying so c4 is still
a very responsible move because uh in
end games you definitely don't want this
sort of fan games with the opponent b3
being kind of stuck now right
um and we can see that ali reza played
bishop g7 it's gonna castle
uh we can see his time management again
like i've not been following the wall
game but it's been like 20 move stops
yeah yeah
and he has 27 minutes left so
yeah not even no not even 20. he doesn't
move 17.
okay yeah
so ikawi doesn't have that much time
left so that means that it was a
difficult position to navigate i mean
like there's a reason that you're done
on 27 minutes after so so few moves but
still
it strikes me as an issue in
because you know
things are definitely not travel from
here like it's not uh it's not gonna be
uh
you know
it's a cruise
no no not at all
uh by the way uh as i'm looking at the
position i i'm attracted to the move
rook d5
but you know maxine what i would love i
would love to see the move knight f5
takes e3 yes
yeah and then that then the white knight
taking over possession of the so like if
i could play queen in
this
i got a dream position right
i don't really like queen c2 because
after queen e6 i don't know what we've
achieved which was queen e4
you see i
on the panel uh i have a reputation
reaction 26 was bad okay
actually quincy two is interesting i was
thinking even about something more
direct now that ali hasn't played bishop
g7 yes uh he closed his options for rook
g8 so g4 struck me as an option right
trying to
force to do the same thing yeah
basically wow
okay that's
that's lifting your kimono though
you're
exposing yourself uh mvl
[Laughter]
yeah i must have the 97 i'm not going to
show what i want but maybe night h4
oh yeah yeah
and this is uh
this is what you want yeah yeah this is
the dream
that you could establish a night there
wonderful um you mentioned that you're
coming definitely it's a safer option
like i like it actually right you
mentioned that you're coming
to
st louis uh we're going to provide you
of course as a wonderful st louis
welcome you got the grand chess tour uh
now that uh the uh the grand chess tour
is also a part of the feed a cycle right
there's you you get two qualifiers what
are your thoughts about your own
candidacy
for a future candidates you want to get
back in the mix
well certainly and
you know i
do think i will have a good chance to
qualify through so manchester but
you know
in any case i would have been ready to
to fight for for a spot among the
candidates because ultimately it's my
goal to play the candidates and to win
them and then
even ultimately to win the match so you
know it's
i haven't qualified so often i've been
very often extremely close and
you know i still haven't given up
i do have another question for you as
well because um i was looking on
the rating the live ratings and i
noticed that um well there's so many
players that are so wonderful and
they've they're very qualified and
they're definitely super grandmasters in
your opinion what does it take to cross
2800 and stay on that level
well
lately it's been basically only magnus
[Laughter]
we should be asking magnus
yeah is this your suggestion
i think so uh
but of course um
i mean
like a lot of players have been you know
in the past few years managing to to get
there and to stay there for at least a
few months uh like for me or a few years
like fabi like 11 at some points
[Music]
and maybe think also i think like the
two most consistent players about from
magnus in the last 10 years were were
fabian levant so you know
i just think it's about
you know
it just means that every player who
managed to cross 28 android like shah
like myself like a cow at some point who
had very high eyes and like
basically we were playing uh definitely
at the level of magnus for a few months
but we didn't manage to to keep it that
way so
i think it's a sort of stability that
magnus pushes to the extreme
and that's kind of lacking maybe
for some of us like we have stability
definitely over 2750
uh quite close to 2800 but staying
over 2800 is a real also
yeah the consistency factor
is is
really really really remarkable there
one more because we have you here and i
want you analyzing stuff we're going to
have to work yeah
between
richie and dingler and it's been crazy
a lot of things happened since we left
it in the in the studio
but black is like
king's stuck in the middle
take us through your thought classes
black is not up upon now
oh i mean it's black to move so yeah
so yeah um
yeah
i don't know so like what i see
immediately is white's king is not safe
i mean it's safe for now but if the
dark bishop
is not there to cover h4 it's definitely
not safe because the king is stuck
while black skin cannot be called as
safe
for obvious reasons
so
it's pretty much a mess
positions that the computer would
evaluate
much better than i do but
i mean
if i were to choose i probably stick
still pick white
but objectively i think black must be at
least fine maybe more than that
um
yeah i must say that doing has been
playing better in the past few
few days and well it's satisfying
because you had a
pretty tough start
of the event
um
on the um
personage of a ding laran
um he's a great player full stop end of
story yes he works incredibly hard to
get to the candidates
and when he gets the candidates it's
almost like everything goes wrong why
why well it's amazing okay so the first
candidates
no
actually the first candidate that he
played he was remarkably consistent i
think he won one game made certain draws
so he was still gathering experience but
very solid performance i would say
second candidate he played was in
under very special circumstances let's
say he was uh
out in quran for like two weeks maybe
more
before after i mean i i can understand
that you know not every player will
react uh well to that and he definitely
didn't so
this time i think it's on him
basically
like i'm just very surprised he hasn't
played
much uh over the ball chess in the past
few months i mean that one is not on him
and at least he could play
over the board in in china in
i think in
in april right so that was more or less
okay
but how do you get to the place only
three days before
and the
just jet flag
i don't know about her i didn't know
about iran but that's uh something uh
not great either but
like there's jet flags there's we're
just
getting back with the touch of top-level
chess you know he hasn't seen
uh all of those guys for for one year no
so
you know i think he definitely
would have wanted to be there like a
week before like uh one hour per hour
one day per hour of jet lag like that's
the bare minimum time zone difference
absolutely
mvl thank you so much for joining us
it's always a pleasure to see you we
look forward to your eventual arrival in
saint louis exactly and uh
you look very well you look healthy you
look how happy nice to see you yeah i
don't have the tension of playing as a
candidate
that's it
yeah thank you thank you very much thank
you maxime all right bye
and uh